what's going on guys this is Rob and the
ending of this video is going to be
crazy but we are back with deceased
which technically we're not supposed to
release until later on this week but I
want to release it today so what we end
up doing here is again picking up on
Earth 2 which in the world of deceased
is basically just another Earth or
another world within the DC Universe
that is habitable for Humanity I know
for all you guys out there who are DC
aficionados and some of you all have
been asking this in the comments is it
Earth 2 in like an alternate universe no
it's not the traditional alternate
reality Earth too it's just like a world
over that way that basically allows
Humanity to live on it right because
it's sustainable it's a human life we're
conducive to human life so what we end
up getting here while all these
different superheroes are basically
marshalling their forces working
alongside the Green Lanterns the
Guardians of the universe is we end up
having the arrival of the black racer
the black racer is basically an aspect
of death so much like you have in Marvel
Comics where you have like mistress
death in DC Comics you have death of the
Endless so it is an actual kind of
cosmic entity if you want to call it
that uh that represents what it means to
officially die right like you're Soul
leaves your body and you go on to the
afterlife but death of the Endless
rarely ever actually interacts with
anybody instead what she basically does
is she largely has avatars so if we take
like the Green Lanterns for example
necron is the avatar for the Green
Lanterns themselves technically it
represents death in the emotional
Spectrum but nonetheless right it
represents like the lack of life but in
effect it is the aspect of death of the
Endless that deals with the Green
Lanterns the black flash deals with the
flash family all the speedsters the
black racer deals with the new gods and
everybody else just dies and their soul
just goes to the afterlife so that's
kind of how these things work right so
they're so again it's really more just
like imagine it was like death of the
Endless just kind of like removes parts
of ourselves and says you're gonna hang
out with the Green Lanterns you're gonna
hang out with the flashes and you're
going to hang out with the new gods and
that's basically how this works right so
Governors they basically deal with the
flesh or deal with death but the way
this thing shows up is we kind of only
get really black racer for a moment or
two technically it's statement is that
these superheroes can't kill it which
leads us into mixy Mr mixopitalic some
guy's been commenting down in the video
knows and been saying that like I've
been pronouncing his name wrong don't
care here's the thing right mix up pedal
like this guy's wildly powerful right he
is immensely powerful the guy's a
reality Warfare right a fifth
dimensional length there's nothing
Beyond his ability to achieve that's one
of the more significant things about his
character and it's why him showing up
here is a pretty big deal I mean you do
have Aries who's kind of thumping his
chest you know in the face of Mixie but
the truth about this is Ares would never
stand a chance against this guy nobody
in this universe would right he's just
that powerful one of the other funny
things is that the conversation that
goes on is that you have the Guardians
of the universe who are directly
speaking with the superheroes and the
superheroes talk about how Erebus is the
one that's basically behind all of this
stuff that when deceased initially
kicked off it really just kind of seemed
like it was Darkseid basically merging
the anti-life equation with the concept
of death and that gave us all these
people who were infected with anti-life
the Revelation that we learned recently
is that Erebus is some kind of entity
that exists out there that we don't
really know anything about but it's just
kind of been moving from Universe to
Universe wiping out everything in
existence by basically spreading
anti-life or by somebody doing what
Darkseid did and inviting irobos into
the universe but the way that it's
talked about here Erebus seems more like
a presence or a concept or an ideology
as opposed to a physical being that
exists out there again we don't really
know anything about it and we're we'll
probably figure out as time goes on but
the Guardians of the universe are aware
of what Erebus is but that's why I say
it's one of those weird things because
you don't really see Superman asking a
question like are you familiar with his
name right or like her name you never
really see them actually given a pronoun
it's more just sort of spoken indirectly
right like you know this name that kind
of a thing so that's why I say it may or
may not be like a physical tangible
being as much as an ideology but the
response of gamthet here is that if
Erebus is at the heart of this then it
changes everything the core cannot be
used to wipe away infected planets all
Green Lanterns are to guard owa the
central power battery must be protected
at all costs now this is an important
distinction to understand here and the
reason why is because remember the
central power battery is the source of
power for the Green Lanterns themselves
but it does this by tapping into the
emotional Spectrum so if you can
consider this as kind of a link right
sort of a chain you have the emotional
Spectrum which channels the power of
willpower into the Green Lantern central
power battery which in turn is channeled
into the Green Lanterns if any of the
Green Lanterns were presumably corrupted
by erebos that would allow it to enter
into the emotional spectrum and by doing
so spread through the emotional spectrum
and basically corrupt it all right like
willpower fear the whole nine yards it
would dominate all life the thing that's
not really said here by Tom Taylor and
really my assumption here is that the
emotional Spectrum as we know exists on
a multiversal level which means every
universe that exists out there can tap
into the emotional Spectrum we've known
that ever since War of the first
lanterns during Jeff John's run on the
Green Lantern storyline and so what this
would mean is that if Erebus was able to
access the emotional Spectrum it could
actually conquer the entirety of the
Multiverse in one Fell Swoop and that
would be nuts right so it's one of those
things where it's like to keep this guy
from contaminant dating all creation
across all existence in the Multiverse
we have to stop in here or at least no
Green Lantern can directly come into
contact with him now the other part of
this is Damien right operating as Batman
asked the question you guys watch the
universe and everything that goes on can
you show us where the spread is Right
show us what the front lines look like
so we know where to send the most
capable heroes or where we should focus
our energies at and the response of
ganthin is like are you serious the
front lines are everywhere man like this
is not some this is not some conflict
where like Darkseid and his forces are
going from this planet to that planet to
that planet they're not following a
linear progression that's what makes the
virus just grow at a geometric rate is
they spread out like a plague and they
conquer a variety of planets all at one
time right they literally just jump from
world to world and they all do it and
that's what leads to the virus spreading
so fast because what he does is he shows
them a world called balavox Vic which is
basically a world that belongs to
kilowatt but there's 16 billion people
on this planet these 16 billion people
just as an example if they were
conquered and taken over by the
anti-life virus using the power of the
anti-life virus and the fact that
they're basically dead they can breathe
in the vacuum of space they would spread
out to the stars and who knows how many
other worlds they would hit but another
world with 10 billion people on it
another world with 5 billion people and
suddenly that Collective 15 billion
people is combined with the 16 billion
people and you've got 31 billion people
traveling around the cosmos conquering
worlds you guys see what I'm talking
about and you see why the universe fell
so fast when it came to the anti-life
virus that it's just one of those things
where everything grows at an exponential
rate and so what ends up happening here
is that as they're talking you end up
having gantha that says that they have
to reform the quintessence of course the
quintessence being some of the most
powerful beings are really the most
powerful beings throughout the entirety
of the DC Universe but the problem here
is that it's literally figured things
out by committee somebody like Guy
Gardner doesn't want to have to deal
with that he's like that's ridiculous
I'm not going to sit around while you
guys vote by committee to figure out
whether or not the universe is worth
saving we're gonna get out there and
we're gonna fight and ultimately the
hands of the Guardians are tied if the
Guardians were for example to shut down
the central power battery and take away
the Green Lantern's source of power then
what happens if the anti-life virus
reaches owa and the Guardians aren't
there there's no one to protect it all
the Green Lanterns fall the central
power battery is left without any form
of protection and then it's game over
right it's just that kind of thing so
honestly what really ends up happening
here is the Green Lanterns actually
leave with kilowatt when he takes off to
go to his home planet in order to
basically try to save his people and
then you have like Mixie and then
Superman and Jonathan Kent now Jonathan
Kent wants to go with Superman to fight
in this battle but the response to
Superman is no like that's not going to
be the case right he literally says this
is one planet right you saw the
guardian's vision there are dozens of
planets that need us billions of lives
being threatened as we speak I wish I
could take you with me keep you near me
keep you safe but I need you to protect
our Two Earths I need you to start
saving the planets the Guardians have
given up on so it's a really significant
moment and the reason why is because in
recent years especially if you go back
to what is it the Superman Lois Clark
comic book by Dan Jurgens where they
basically brought back the free
flashpoint Superman that Jonathan Kent
was a little kid even going into like
super sons and different stories like
that Action Comics rebirth Superman
rebirth it was largely Superman trying
to protect his son but ever since Brian
Michael bendis's trash ass run on
Superman where basically he aged up uh
Jonathan Kent and turn him into a
teenager which was what nobody wanted to
have happen but bendus did it anyway
because that guy just doesn't know how
to write Superman but it basically led
to Superman kind of having to take a
more hands-off approach to Jonathan Kim
this kind of conversation is honestly
the sort of stuff that we should have
been seeing during bendis's run it's
less of Superman trying to protect his
son and it's more Superman trying to
teach his son to be a more effective
hero it's what we saw during Action
Comics rebirth and Superman rebirth
which were amazing stories just kind of
a Sidetrack here if you ever want to
know what some of the best Superman
stories were in recent years check out
the videos that I did on Action Comics
and Superman rebirth they're phenomenal
oh my God those stories were amazing but
the thing here is that ultimately
Jonathan just kind of has to stay behind
and Superman takes off along with
kilowog and everybody else to arrive on
his planet now the funny thing about
this is that for the people of kilowog
they share a kind of hive mind right
which is to say they're highly
empathetic and they can feel the
emotions of every other member on their
race and so the result of this is that
when kilowatt gets there his mind
basically rejoins the collective and all
he feels is absolute Terror now if
you're not familiar with kilowog and the
Green Lanterns This Moment's lost on you
but if you are familiar with kilowog
it's huge and the reason why for those
of you guys who really aren't familiar
with this character kilowatts hardcore
man he's like the drill instructor for
the Green Lantern court but this guy
he's got it where it counts and if
you're stranded out there by yourself
kilowog is really the guy you'd want
coming to your side the fact that he's
quite literally shivering in his boots
right now is a testament to the terror
he feels connected with the rest of his
people and the terror they feel which is
being fed into him but his his kind of
emotional state is bolstered when you
get the arrival of the rest of the Green
Lanterns but this is important because
remember the Green Lanterns derived
their abilities from The Willpower
portion of the emotional Spectrum the
more willpower they have the more
capable they are the less willpower they
have meaning their confidence begins to
wane the less capable they are so
without the other Green Lantern showing
up here there's a better than fair
chance that literally kilowog would have
just been annihilated because at the end
of the day his willpower just wouldn't
have been where it traditionally would
have been because of the fear that he
was feeling right just the weakness of
the Green Lanterns and so what you have
is of course you have the Green Lanterns
you've got Superman you got all these
guys who are trying to protect the
people of kilowog as best they can enter
Supergirl now the funny thing about this
is that Superman has not met Supergirl
yet remember like during the deceased in
in this story in this universe Supergirl
never crash landed on earth right she
was never sent there instead she was
sent to the world of the new Gods she
was sent to uh new genesis where High
father was to reside but by the time she
got there they'd already been infected
with the anti-life virus so as soon as
she got there she was immediately
subdued and taken over she didn't stand
a chance Superman fans never seen her
before and that's why he asked the
question who are you why are you wearing
that symbol and so the result of this is
that she's able to annihilate some of
the people on this world Superman's kind
of hopeless to Stand By and Watch
because out of nowhere comes Darkseid
and Supergirl just kind of watches on as
Darkseid intends to thrash Superman
enter Mixie right Mr mix pitlick himself
dude it's so cool to see this guy right
this there's never been a time that I'm
aware of in DC Comics when Mixie is
fought dark side I'm not aware of that
at all but we get this amazing moment
here right literally he says okay that's
enough new God what should I turn you
into a houseplant a persuasive essay and
it says all mixy had to do was think it
and Darkseid would have been undone but
he didn't have time to think and this is
one of the things to remember right
remember how the anti-life equation
initially spread throughout Earth
remember how it started smartphones TVs
tablets people saw it they witnessed the
equation and doing so they were
corrupted by it and that's literally
what Tom Taylor says right the virus
spread in two ways and while Mixie was
no doubt confident he couldn't be harmed
which he couldn't be hurt by dark side
he could still see and all it took was a
corrupted Mother Box to show him the
anti-life equation and its game over
Mixie is infected like that right he's
the most powerful force under control of
the anti-life equation right now this
guy could literally undo everybody with
just a thought now this is the way that
Tom Taylor plays this and I actually
like the way that he does this under any
normal circumstance if mixy was
basically full of his own capabilities
right meaning he had his own he had he
had his own mind and he was operating
rationally and stuff like that there's
no limit to the kind of stuff he can do
what it looks like the anti-life
equation does is it kind of reduces
people down to a more primitive state so
he's not as capable as he normally would
be now whether or not this is something
you agree with depends on you know on on
how you feel like the story should end
right like your own personal opinions
will infer whether or not you agree with
this kind of thing which makes sense
right I mean everybody interprets
stories in their own way but the reality
here is that instead of Mixie just
snapping his fingers and everybody turns
into like a bouquet of roses he
literally just like starts attacking
everyone now kilowog and Jon Stewart
respond as soon as it happens but Mixie
immediately like seizes control of him
the former protective orb as best they
can it gets crushed Jon Stewart and
kilowatt die like that like they're just
dead gone out of the picture it's one of
the reasons why I love Tom Taylor's
writing when it comes to this stuff man
is because at any point in time any
superhero can die it's one of the
greatest things about his riding when it
comes to these alternate reality stories
because by and large when it comes to DC
no matter what happens in a story like
Superman will always come out on top
right the Green Lanterns will eventually
always come out on top it's always that
way right it's just the superheroes
always win it's just how long will it
take them to win and what will they have
to go through until they do when it
comes to these alternate reality stories
by Tom Taylor anything goes right like
there's no rules and it's the reason why
these stories that he does are so
phenomenal right they're absolutely
amazing because basically with this
world destroyed and Mixie Unleashed he
immediately takes off for the world of
owa and when he gets there he
annihilates the central power battery
and we get this amazing point where it's
like end everywhere Green Lanterns were
severed from their power exposing the
core to gravity and to the vacuum of
space they're literally just suffocating
out there with no oxygen whatsoever
right it's almost like from Injustice
when Kyle Raynor was pulled apart by the
by the celestial core and dropped into
the sun right just like killed in space
it was pretty gruesome right it was
pretty brutal but the thing about this
is that while the quintessence meets
you've got Hera of the Greek gods you've
got the Phantom stranger who even goes
as far as to say like the wizard Shazam
is dead High father is a slave to the
anti-life equation I was almost
destroyed by Trigon fighting this which
I'm not aware that we ever actually got
a story where the Phantom stranger
fought Trigon and if we didn't we need
that maybe I'm missing something if I am
let me know down in the comments because
maybe it's a story that we didn't cover
and if we didn't we will fix that with a
quickness let me know like
let me know down in the comment section
what's going on but the bigger point of
the Phantom strangers making is the
quintessence numbers are decreasing this
universe will likely be lost to earbuds
but the response of the Specter right
the living embodiment of God's Vengeance
wrath whatever you want to call it like
literally they kind of refer to it as
both his response is I'm not going to
let this universe fall I'm not going to
let another Universe fall to arabah so
he literally takes off and then suddenly
the power of the Green Lanterns starts
to restore but it starts to come back
and we end up finding out the reason why
is because the Specter sees control of
the central power battery of the Green
Lanterns reconstituted it and wielding
the power of the Green Lanterns and The
Willpower of emotion of the emotional
Spectrum which will likely lead to him
becoming a Green Lantern he Fashions the
sword of God and then goes after Mixie
and that's the end thanks for watching
guys no this is actually the Cliffhanger
though right so in the next video we
will cover what happens next thank you
guys for watching and I will catch you
all later
peace